Before moving on, I want to make a brief
comment about your goals as a parallel
algorithm designer with
respect to work and span.
One goal is to achieve
a degree of work that matches
the best sequential algorithm.
I called this goal one of
achieving work optimality.
Now I want you to hearken back to the
days of sequential algorithm design yore
just for a sec.
Now from what you learned back then,
your holy grail was to
find a linear time or even sub-linear
time sequential algorithm.
This isn't always possible but
it's a good goal.
And since you want to be work optimal,
that grail is the same with respect
to work in the parallel case.
So what's the holy grail for span?
So what I'm going to do is,
I'm always going to ask you to find
algorithms with polylogarithmic span.
So polylogarithmic means
log n to some power.
So that might be log n, log squared n,
log cubed n, and so on.
So always remember this principle
of poly-logarithmic span.
That's what we'll mean
when we say low span.
So what's special about poly logs?
Well, since log n grows asymptotically
a lot more slowly than n, and
since O(n) is our work goal then
poly-logarithmic span ensures that
the average available
parallelism grows with n.
Now, you'll always have to use your
judgement about whether a given parallel
algorithm has good working span but
please use these ideals as a guide.